all right well assemblyman roberts uh
let's let's first just talk about some
of the news of the day if we can
um obviously what took place on
wednesday up out on dc on capitol hill i
saw your tweet about it i think it was
this morning
um just give me some thoughts from your
end of what we saw in the nation's
capital yesterday
well actually you know i said something
out uh last last night and you know
and uh we're a a democracy in a country
that
the world should look up to and this is
not
indicative of uh what we saw yesterday
is not indicative
of what we should tolerate in our nation
and
it's it's completely uncalled for
um and i
appreciate that we're talking federal
government and you know you're
in in carson city not in washington dc
but
is there some responsibility and i know
you obviously have history in law
enforcement is there some responsibility
or some accountability that needs to be
addressed
on your end and where do you think that
responsibility should go
well considering what occurred there i
mean uh
there's i think there's a number of
things that you need to look at
from a law enforcement standpoint is um
you need to be concerned about your
government buildings being overrun
i mean you know that's a challenge i
don't know if the capitol police
were restrained uh by things that
occurred this past summer that they
didn't have less than lethal
options and or or they were
underprepared i i don't know i'm sure
or at least i'm hopeful that somebody
will will flush that out
i know that security concerns uh
are an issue here as we get ready to go
to the legislative session
i i know a few of my peers have
expressed uh you know as well some
leadership
have expressed concerns about security
at the legislature
um you know you put covet on top of that
you know and you know building
restrictions um
you know it'd be interesting to see you
know what we come up with
to allow the public to have access to
the building
how about political responsibility
well i mean look we all have a
responsibility to
to do the right thing to uh
send the right messages uh to the public
and give reassurances that government
is going to hold people accountable and
we're to include ourselves
let's switch gears and talk about the
the legislative session on the horizon
um everyone that i've talked to and i'm
sure everyone you
have talked to and you know firsthand
it's going to be
bad there's a lot of cuts on the horizon
there's not a lot of money to go around
um what are the big budget holes
um and how are you going to work with
democrats to try and
achieve your needs and achieve the needs
of your constituents while also still
you know staying within the confines of
the budget
well i mean during a special session uh
you know we cut the the
budgets uh pretty far back i i think
you're going to see a continuation
of a a lot of those cuts uh due
you know due to the revenue shortfall
from you know the governor's closures
um you know obviously the the budget
you know it's got really three big holes
you know big
three big items that we fund you know
it's it's
uh education uh you know health care
uh you know and uh you know in public
safety issues
you know and actually delivering
government services um
you know to the state and so you know
those are those are your those are your
biggest
biggest ones and you know we're going to
have to ensure that we continue to
provide
services to the citizens of nevada
uh but i think we also need to be
cognizant that the federal government
did put a lot of money into our state
under the first
relief act under covid i mean almost 19
billion dollars
have came to our state you know in our
biannual budget is eight eight
eight point something million you know
uh
so there's a lot of money that's been
infused into government
uh we need to completely flush that out
on where um
those general fund dollars are being
stashed
uh i know we there was uh some
at the at the end of uh the year
the calendar year we we moved some money
into the general fund
and you know and and to carry over so
you know that money will be used to
shore it up and some of the revenue
projections actually came in
a little better than where they were
previously
predicted but really fall short of what
where we should be
let me ask you this you when you're
talking about the federal money coming
into nevada
you're using words you know where the
money's been stashed or
and are you um
concerned about where the money that has
already come to nevada is
has already gone or where it has not
gone
well you know i'm on a subcommittee to
look at where some of the the money has
been spent
you know there there's there's there's
been
uh there's been some visibility on it i
can tell you that
uh peers me and my peers even on both
sides of the aisle to some degree
was a little frustrated with knowing
exactly where
all the funds uh went early we're
catching up now uh during the last
physical or
the last interim finance committee uh
there was quite a bit of money that was
used to
uh supplant uh some government salaries
so that
free some other funds that
actually you know we already funded
for government salaries so there's 160
million
there that uh is
in the general fund which okay what are
we going to do with that can we you know
can
in my opinion i believe it should be
used or utilized
to provide further relief to the
citizens of nevada and not necessarily
to shore up
you know government salaries we
expressed some of that in that hearing
um but you know what's done is done it's
better than sending it back to
washington
uh we were up on a deadline so
uh we'll flush all that out uh we'll be
at the table
and you know we'll figure out the best
course i don't believe 12 percent
reductions across the board are the
answer uh you know so to be interesting
to see what the governor's proposal
will be uh you know coming up and then
we'll work from there
obviously you were former assistant
sheriff and and we've talked
with current sheriff lombardo about
issues of police reform in light of the
black lives matter protests
uh in my conversations with him he has
essentially said
at that time anyway he had not had a lot
of conversations with state lawmakers
with
clark county committee there hasn't been
too much of an in-depth discussion of
what's going to happen
up in carson city at the legislative
session so
how much of that disgust reform do you
think will actually get discussed at the
legislative session
well you know i think we did some things
during a special session
uh that uh law enforcement approved
uh for the most part in the state i know
there's gonna be some uh
some bills that are going to want to
push reform further
um you know i i think
folks like sheriff lombardo and police
leaders in our state
are willing to be at the table and talk
about reform issues
i think what a lot of people don't
realize is that
a lot of things that we do in nevada are
considered best practices
in the in the nation uh we can always
make improvements and
you know i think you know we're always
willing to be at the table to talk about
it
um and i haven't seen a profession
well you know i've been in it i was in
it for 30 some odd years
and it has completely changed you know
through my whole course
uh of of uh my career and it continues
to change
and i think law enforcement knows that
that we need to be responsive to the
citizens and if they
if they have an issue or they have
concerns then we need to sit down and
talk about it and
and make changes as they need to be done
another major issue and probably uh one
of the biggest one involves education
funding that's
kind of a perennial or i should say
perennial but every legislative session
is an issue uh what kind of bills do you
see coming down the pipe with regards to
not only funding but any sort of uh
changes to education operations
let's talk k-12 education what's what's
gonna come down the pipe
i mean last last session there was some
funding formulas that
you know that were uh approved by the
legislature to shift funding i think we
really need to see
let that work its way out uh we still
aren't completely back in the classroom
and so
i would be interested to see how
that has impacted the budget you know it
would logically you would think that
there would be
some budget relief from not actually
being in the classroom
but but i know we had to spend some
money to get
you know to get us up and running uh for
remote learning but a lot of that
burden was put on uh federal federal
relief dollars
so so what you know we need to see what
what the school year looks like
uh going forward um you know i don't
think that
throwing more money at an issue is
necessarily
the right answer uh but you know
education is
is a priority for us it's it's a big
chunk of our budget
and i think we need to really look at it
closely uh when we're
when we're looking at cuts you know and
and make some of those
uh you know some of the the latter ones
another issue that's
been going on since the beginning of the
pandemic i've heard i remember listening
to a couple of interim finance committee
meetings about dieter
and especially at the beginning and it's
still a lingering issue we get calls
about it all the time
here what how would you
grade dieter's response to the pandemic
and the unemployment
and what kind of conversations might
there be
up at the legislative session to try and
help these people out well
look i i don't think anyone anticipated
the landslide
of um you know of applications that
that that we had coming into dieter
so i will give them that right i you
know i believe that
it's unprecedented nobody could be
prepared for that
i think there was a significant amount
of lag time
in in ramping up and
addressing uh a lot of issues i think
accessibility has been a challenge
i mean that's that's been a majority of
my constituent
uh complaints and what i've worked on is
people can't can't get into the system
they can't call anybody uh the computer
system would lock them out there's a
number of those things
you know uh it took us a while it took
dieter a while to set up a task force
to work through those you know i think
i'm not getting nearly the amount of
complaints uh that i did
early on so i think we've resolved some
of those
we made some changes during the special
session to allow the director
some leeway to make adjustments i think
those have been some benefits
but i think there's still a number of
people out there that are frustrated
with the system
and we really need to take a a good look
at how we can make some improvements to
it
um but because it it
it is it did not you know serve nevadans
well especially when you know we had as
high unemployment and still continue to
have one of the highest unemployment
uh you know numbers in the nation so we
need we need to really take a look at
that again and continue to make
improvements there
i know people call us and say they can't
get answers you kind of address that
we've called to try and get answers from
time to time from peter
we don't get them very much are you how
would you characterize the transparency
or lack thereof
from dieter well there wasn't
there there wasn't a lot of transparency
uh
in the last in the first i don't know
six to eight months you know i guess uh
during the pandemic
uh there was a change in directors uh
they were
they were very overwhelmed um with the
workflow
our constituent services uh had an
opportunity to have
you know some direct contact with with
theater
the new director um ms cafaretta
has actually reached out to legislators
and so we
you know i've had conversations with her
and so i have the ability
to to reach out for specific issues and
so
there's there's been a lot of
improvement
from where it was um but it it it took
it took us a long time to get there and
i i think that frustrated legislators
uh and citizens alike and you know we
need to
learn from it and make some adjustments
moving forward
final question i know this has gone
longer than probably you expected no
words
the mechanics of the legislative session
uh obviously during the interim period
there's
it's been mostly virtual all of it's
been virtual essentially do you
envision that continuing i i certainly
hope not i believe
you know i've participated in some uh
some phone calls with some
national organizations and and heard
from speakers
uh and in folks in other legislators
legislatures
around the country and and and other
bodies have found a way to have
um you know limited public access and
reduce public access you know we're not
gonna
i just under the current conditions i
just you know there's probably no way to
be 100
open but certainly we can figure out a
way to have limited capacity
allow people to to testify in hearings
uh to be able to ask questions we we
can't do what we did during a special
session
you know and have public comment for two
minutes and
like what we do in a lot of our interim
committees is is
you know public comment is just not the
way
to you know to to develop policy
and when we're gonna be faced with
difficult
decisions with like you talked about or
like we talked about already
education you know uh health care
deter things like that if we if we don't
have the ability to ask us for experts
questions
or citizens to be able to weigh in
and actually give us their experiences i
don't know how we can effectively solve
problems and develop policy to address
the issues that
impact the state so we need to be open
in some shape or form
thank you very much for uh today
appreciate it we haven't seen it
when you have all these pent up
legislative questions they all sort of
come out at once so i appreciate the uh
appreciate no worries and i i appreciate
your time and anytime you need you guys
anything let me know